ils ont été utilisés contre la
tuberculose le sras c'est maintenant le
coronavirus les masques n 95 sont des
équipements certifiés ajustable et qui
ont la propriété crucial d'intercepter
les aérosols ses fines gouttelettes en
suspension dans l'air
en fait c'est la taille en fait des
trous au père 2.3 micro ondes et des
très petites roues qui vont intercepter
si on rue d'ham bassam est rejetée on
part de plus 99 % par exemple des
bactéries certains bastille et des virus
à la différence des masques chirurgicaux
classique les n95 sont à privilégier
dans des cas précis dans des situations
où on est dans des par exemple des
manoeuvres comme l'intubation mettre un
patient sous respirateur ça va engendrer
beaucoup des aérosols et ça ça prend un
masque n 95 pour les arrêter mais pour
bien d'autres usages le simple masque
chirurgical convient qu'à l'urgence on
connaît pas encore trop le patient
systématiquement maintenant reporté un
match comme celui-là masse de procédure
donc avec des lunettes de protection
ces éléments là dessus qu'ils vont
porter ces masques là ça va être
on va leur mettre sur pour que s'ils
toussent qui a pas de gouttelettes qui
soit rejetée pour être efficace il faut
que l'ajustement du masque n 95 soit
parfait et répondent à un test
d'étanchéité
c'est pourquoi il existe une multitude
de taille et de marques de masques n95
un peu comme des pointures de chaussures
c'est écrit sur ma carte d'hôpital
le modèle qui me convient 15-12 médium
et l' or à 10,70 points kim ho kim ont
préféré mais j'avais dû 18,60 la
différence défense il faut que ça fasse
à ta face au front le personnel soignant
redoutent une pénurie d'équipement alors
que certains font un usage inapproprié
des masques et que les réserves
diminuent à vue d'oeil
même si l'organisation mondiale de la
santé ne recommande pas de réutiliser
les masques m 95 pour le moment certains
hôpitaux ont décidé de le faire hier
avant que je regarde toute la
littérature j'étais sceptique et hier
soir jusqu'à 11 heures le soir ça a été
ma tâche principale est donc à regarder
les différents articles qui sont sortis
à regarder les rapports qui ont été
faits aux états unis je suis assez à
l'aise de dire que si on est capable
d'avoir ce qu'il faut pour les retraités
c'est à dire le peroxyde d'hydrogène
parce que c'est ce qu'on a chez nous
on peut les retraités à compter de
mercredi l'hôpital sainte justine va
récupérer les masques n95 afin de les
désinfecter et de pouvoir les réutiliser
au moins cinq fois alors je lis un tout
autre débat sur des masques mais c'est
d'autres masques alors il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se demandent si oui ou non ils
devraient porter des masques en tout
temps on parle de mon masque fait maison
pour ne pas contaminer les autres
exactement se couvrir le visage portait
une écharpe ou un autre masque en tissu
justement la question se pose elle nous
est posée tout au long de la journée par
de nombreux messages que les
téléspectateurs nous envoie écouté selon
la santé publique oui si on est
contaminé évidemment faudrait se couvrir
faudrait surtout éviter tout contact
avec autrui maintenant pour ceux et
celles qui ne sont pas malades
est ce qu'on doit se couvrir le visage
se fabriquer un masque maison le docteur
horacio arruda a été très claire
aujourd'hui dans son point de presse
et il dit entre autres que ça peut créer
à z un faux sentiment de sécurité que ça
doit surtout pas remplacer un excellent
lavage de mains à ce sujet docteur
arruda
quelqu'un veut faire des masques en
tissu ok je veux te rend dingue je
voudrais c'est pu le faire je pense que
ça peut être fait mais faut pas qu'ils
l'utilisent un masque comète en pensant
que c'est justement ce qui va régler son
problème il doit avoir une hygiène
impeccable des maps etc
si vous portez un masque et que vous
voulez toucher
vous avez touché des objets puis vous
sentez sécuriser ces nuisibles ou je
boxais sunwing c'est que les gens
oublient les autres méthodes qui sont
plus importantes que le port du masque
oui dont casey blake sur les autorités
veulent surtout éviter là que les gens
se précipiter dans les pharmacies pour
aller se procurer justement des masques
donc débat à suivre ses pas tout à fait
réglé la thur
merci beaucoup je vous en prie